this just our social game and it's just
us I think that's a problem
I am Nick Gillespie with reason TV and I
am talking with Jeff Tucker he is the
director of content at the foundation
for economic education which i think is
the oldest it is longest-lived
libertarian organization crazy look it
was founded in 1946 1947 Owenton the
history books what was going on price
controls
you know heavily regulated industry is a
wartime economy yeah and a lot of people
just at the time thought that liberalism
liberalism was was dead and gone but a
handful of people you know including
Lawrence Pritikin Leonard read you know
and it's just a really a small a small
group and wasn't like Ludwig von Mises
always hang because yeah he came over in
1940 and didn't really have a home yeah
anywhere really you want to stay in New
York so he didn't have a university
position
well Fee brought him on board you know
and made him a kind of a house
intellectual yeah Henry Hazlitt yeah at
the time you know who wrote economics
one lesson in 1946 also and so when I
went to work for free I went back
because I wanted to do something about
reviving this editorial mission know
what I didn't want to do the same thing
everybody else is doing I'm gonna do
something different and I wanted to
figure out you know maybe there's some
people were missing so I went back and
looked looked at the early writings of
all these guys so when the night report
is a night I tell you I found something
really interesting it might be interest
to you there weren't a lot of what we
called libertarians around at the time
they didn't have any they didn't have
like we have a movement you know so that
opposed a special editorial burden on
them they had to speak in a way to
everybody or to anyone who would listen
and I think that affected the way they
thought and the way they rode so they
had to like every piece had to sort of
make sense for anybody who happened to
pick it up so they're in that they're
showing their math they're making their
arguments clear they're not assuming a
lot of foreknowledge that's right and
they're not using a specialized language
right so they they know better than to
end and it's written from us today
yeah but so they split to a general a
general audience and the values of the
time and trying to make a practical case
for human liberty in the early stages of
fee publications did they link economics
to that broader issue there's Liberty
was always a moral concern and it's
interesting because I saw a
correspondence between 9r and mm-hmm
and Leonard read and she really wanted
the organization to be called something
like I don't know the Institute for the
defense of radical capitalism with some
people that you know and Leonard was you
know he came out of Industry you know he
came out of commerce and he understood
sales and marketing and he knew that if
he called the foundation for economic
education something very plain and
innocuous that that they could push
radical ideas and a mainstream framework
and what's one of their early
publications I may be getting this wrong
but it was something vaguely Milton
Friedman and sticklers about rent
control yes and that was the piece that
that drew Murray Murray Rothbard my old
friend and to into an excited
relationship with the idea for everybody
and they did this with with you know
many many people now the height of the
height of the Freeman circulation was
was achieved in the 1960s with 50,000
which which I mean reason gets that
every day and we do now so it was a
small market relatively small market but
what I think is interesting is that they
had a big job and they had really know
where to begin but just reaching
mainstream people and here's the thing I
think we have something to learn from
that because as we've become a movement
that's very exciting we love the
movement we talk as libertarians we come
to libertarianism where we're at
students for liberty where they've got
about 1,700 kids
yeah hundred countries and we all you
know yeah we're all the same Facebook
groups and we you know we follow each
other but and that's good nothing bad
about that but it does give rise to I
think certain temptations to to speak in
our own vernacular our own really high
liturgical language with each other
right know that normal people can
understand and it also tempts us to sort
of dig ever deeper into sectarian
battles and and here's the other thing
it's a matter of how we think of
ourselves are we you know a chosen
marginalized group
you know that's that's that's gonna be
forever you know hanging around together
is this just our social gang right and
it's just us I think that's a problem so
what are some of the articles that you
do that you try to breach abroad right
so I don't know if you've ever attempted
to do this in editor but I've never done
this before never tried this before but
I try to classify every article as
either inReach or outreach yeah by that
I mean we cultivating the libertarian
spirit Amara they already convinced or
my created content that that you use a
libertarian might be willing to share in
your Facebook account even though your
pastor your mother your friends regular
on it because you've had a compelling
enough and what I've learned from the
metrics is that this is the challenge to
create content that gets the second
third and fourth share right what's like
the most recent pichia did that was
successful in those terms a way you
mentioned my review of young pope and
yeah and we the young hope is the HBO
show with Jude Law and we're you raised
Catholic by any chance
well I am but you know you're kind of a
big relationship with cat okay so I was
raised Catholic and I and I actually I
love it I'm a I'm a pro lapsed Catholic
at this point I'm like totally it just
it's collapsing its I can never be right
I mean I love the show but talk a little
bit about that piece goes yeah it seemed
to be doing some thing we do we try to
review all the new stuff on five flex
and we try to write regular reviews in
other words I'm looking for a
libertarian spin on things I want really
regular reviews right that I as a
libertarian I'm going to write because I
see things different for that rose and I
hope to add value to it you know well
you know one of the things we used to
talk about at reason and you know you
over the years you come up with
different things but we wanted to be not
we didn't want to just be a magazine for
libertarians they said we want it to be
a magazine by libertarians because your
worldview would fail out and it's a good
way to think about it
so I'm good way to think more reason
does a good job what was your insight
for the young Pope because I thought I
was kind of clever well I I think the
whole thing was structured in a way to
respond to the rise of
kind of a reactionary right well in the
Europe and in the United States this
show is very popular in Italy yeah so
young Pope shows up he had a regular
career he had the perfect bishop career
just the right training and never
revealed much about himself just very
pastoral as they say they knew he was a
conservative because crystal could his
teachers and look at his temperament and
that sort of thing what they didn't know
is that he had a you know heart agenda
and really a kind of revanchist agenda
to recapture what would have been lost
and he really does adopt all these forms
that are essentially pre-vatican too you
know and there are moments the thing
that just had me just cracking up you
know he delayed weeks his opening
lecture to the end and went by the final
thing the thing comes long he's carried
in yeah and it's here right away the
most outrageous liturgical year seeming
to revive the temporal power oh and he
brings back the Triple Crown you know
Table six cable but and then at the same
time he in he is hyper conservative and
traditional but he breaks all the forms
he even starts smoking again yeah that's
my kid which is and also you know I
thought it was very interesting for me
to follow it because his commitment is
entirely intellectual but it wasn't
organically connected with the real real
experience of the church now yeah and
what he finds is that there's no going
back
which is not to say that it's inevitable
we're going to do forever a tentative
Frances direction the point is that
whatever you're going to build you have
to build from what actually really
exists well and you also talked about it
how the young pope and again this is a
show that was filmed in Italy a year or
year and a half ago so it's pre Trump
but he's also kind of the perp one way
to talk about Trump because he has a
very set strong set of views that he is
going to force on people that's right
whether he lies you know I I read
reviews of things partly because I'm
dodging my own deadlines but it's also
like I had a professor once who said
look any any criticism is good if it
makes that if it makes the thing more
interesting and I thought that your
young Pope piece it worked really well
had you seen it yeah yeah yeah he used
to like
never gave us some insight right no and
it's and it also made me think about
Trump
all right you know who I am I'm not a
fan of Trump one of the things that I do
find a tract of about him is his
willingness to break with decorum and
just be like shut the [ __ ] up like we're
doing it my way now and he will say this
is the way it should always be done and
that is its chaos inducing I think it is
not maybe but it's yeah it it could make
an opening for a more radical cause
that's all you know you know on the
other side we had a review of of this
movie about the crowd you know and now
there you have an opposite case you know
because you have somebody who's a
similar leader but she throws away your
personality of personal desires her own
individual wishes and everything I was
deference to know to the long tradition
and and in a way the crown makes the
case that there's merit in that right
because the disturbance itself can
create you know an atmosphere in which
bad things can happen she was to defer
to the pastor and in fact in the
previous generation you know they had
the king that that renounced his you
know the sake of love you know yeah and
the monarchy was like don't ever do
anything like that because that's yeah
that's not what the people need we needs
wrong but that show makes the case for
more of a continuity or a slow change I
think we as libertarians you know are
drawn to both of us part of us was to
disturb you and upset and overthrow well
and this is also a little concerned
about that we have a difference between
a kind of like Rothbart and high for
difference and you know I think all good
libertarians toggle between rope Hayek
enough well we will stop it here but
what I want to congratulate you on
because this you know is on really
revitalizing fee as the material is good
this opens up a way of talking about
libertarianism as well as ideas as well
as current popular culture in ways that
are just it's very very true it really
is Liberty is everything and it belongs
to everybody and and we should speak to
everybody
can and not think of ourselves as a
small sect but you know as me as I said
for the common good for everybody we
have been talking with Jeff Tucker he is
the director of content at the
foundation for economic education feed
work Jeff thanks so much it's my
pleasure
I think for a reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
[Music]